the paint job on this Airbus A320 leaves
little doubt over what's on board
[Applause]
it's the World Cup trophy arriving in
Mexico City
this is the first time in history the
World Cup is so close to Mexico and in
the city's most popular area
[Music]
for Mexican football fans it's not just
the World Cup trophy that's arrived
it's World Cup fever
[Music]
the experience has been perfect I love
football and watching all these families
come together just to see the trophy has
been amazing
[Music]
Mexico is only a first stop in the
trophies tour of Latin America the next
stops include Brazil Uruguay Argentina
Ecuador and Costa Rica the 2022 World
Cup trophy tour will for the first time
include a visit to all 32 qualifying
Nations giving more fans of the
beautiful game a chance to see this
iconic trophy in person
[Music]
the World Cup trophy tour will stop in a
total of 51 countries and territories
finishing its run in Doha Qatar just
before the greatest tournament on Earth
kicks off on November 20th
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City